get up your fellow herald problems and
then um
smack your eggs here with this in the
club
smack your eggs yeah wait if it
just falls over nice dude
[Music]
this is stone house orphanage
use okay apparently they're assuming i'm
a speed reader
so i'm assuming this is some kind of an
orphanage
use left mouse to interact alright
lovely portraits i i thought
oh go my god
i'm sister maria what can i do for you i
was gonna say i'm a reporter
investigating missing children but uh
you know what you
uh you have a lovely day you have a
lovely life if you have life
and i'm on go okay goodbye how do i
close this door
i'm investigating runaway is not missing
my dear lamb
it's unfortunate that not all souls
except the care we provide
dun come in let me show you around look
no no
no no no no no no
no no no apparently also i'm recording
this
my face is a camera got a huge first
person rig
right here watching you you make any
funny moves
we'll mess you up our face
this is our sitting room as you can see
we interview prospective parents here
sometimes i read the children their
verses here if they're well behaved
oh why don't we talk here why do you
don't you
stop sliding across the floor all
weirdly and stop staring at me
all right very well let us begin begin
what
what do you wish to know so many things
do you run that by yourself
i do indeed god it's a lifetime of work
but it truly is my calling
okay who were the children who went
missing two little boys
five and ten years old i'm afraid i
can't tell you their names
it's to protect their privacy you
understand ah
yeah i'm an investigator trying to find
the kids
i don't need their names i definitely
don't need to know their names
where are the children now around deer
they're around
they're very independent if a little
shy i want to see the rest apparently
very well let's continue yeah
yeah okay all right
wait a minute we'll take care of each
other here all right
wait wait a minute watch out for each
other you know i just finished preparing
the soup for tonight
why don't you try some why don't i don't
why don't i not do that oh just slurpity
blurpity very good oh great
soup thank you delicious soup is my
favorite actually if you knew that about
me
what is that on the ground over there oh
it's children's
toys yeah let's soup it up soup
time the pot is full of rust-colored
stew
you mean brown is this what you usually
eat
our meals change day to day we eat
whatever we come
by i trust in the lord to provide
i don't believe in grocery stores where
do you think the children went
oh nowhere good sweet lamb of that you
can be certain
all right super clock the churns in your
stomach
why are you finished come along then
wow your house is really wibbly in the
wind
check the foundations all right i'll
chill all right
is this where the ch
and make their prayers in the evening
you're looking a bit unsteady my dear
why don't you lie down for a bit
[Music]
you may leave your camera there on the
tray
[Music]
good idea
uh good idea lady um
i guess the kids don't need sheets sure
plop oh
[Music]
doink all right just gonna have myself
an old lay down
that's much better
oh no just rest little lamp
no no oh
no oh at least you got the camera and
not me
good stuff i shouldn't have had that
soup
that was creepy i i did like that it was
a little silly but also it was
nice and creepy moving on all right so
you you guys are in for a treat
this is actually not three square three
query games
three square three scary games this is
12 scary games because
this game has 10 and normally i do three
so two others after this one
it's ten ten mini horror games
i love that though i do love that that
is cool this interface
right there that's cool okay starting
[Music]
take out the brains oh
oh i didn't take a oh too slow
next oh what's for dinner
time to go what do you mean time to go
oh
we gotta go we gotta go
all right
well i didn't do it but that's okay
because i
am prepared to do it again
i love this but this is already cool
spell spell what
blood
what does it mean good question i don't
know
abduct oh
[Music]
batteries up
power oh come on huh how's that not
enough
i'm really wailing on it pick up
okay but nobody's
i love this where's nosferatu good
question
where is nosferatu
nosferati oh there he is
ah there it is
oh shoot i missed
oh no ah
i love this i love this this is so fun
this is so fun
[Music]
i was assuming i might have to do long
strokes
[Music]
oh escaping it
hello sir
i'm going to spell spookies
[Music]
what does
fine three-page slender man there's a
page
there's a page slenderman's other man oh
slendy
please all right i really love this this
is super fun
[Music]
oh my god what oh oh
i see oh no please lady no i know god
i gotta beat this but i have to win 20
in a row that's nuts
hell
finally got that one
hello hello i'm not gonna make it on
this one because i only got one life
left but
now i'm starting to get the idea okay
i'm actually gonna go this one first
i think this will be moderately faster
oh yes
scream okay scream scream
oh my god oh hey
hey god okay well now we're gonna get it
now we're gonna get it
[Music]
got it close call yeah right
i gotta get out of there i gotta get out
of there oh is that [ __ ]
i don't understand this one
i don't think it's just wailing on it it
can't be right
ten i'm halfway there my god there's so
many of these okay fine three pages
got him okay i don't know what this
one's about
what is how do you do that one too slow
don't even too slow
all right where is he there he is if i
get if i get the flashlight one again
i'm doomed because i don't know how to
make it
oh it's getting faster
[Music]
okay haunt hey
u oh no no no oh god damn it all right
oh it's right there all right screw that
okay i'm not gonna be able to beat that
one but i encourage you guys to try
there that was fun
that was fun that was fun if you beat it
let me know in the comments
good stuff spooky very spooky almost
this spooky
okay moving on this one is called
the baby in yellow night one
the sitter it's time for bed the child
is that what you think creepy creepy
all right so what are you about game i
hate it
i really hate it i hate it
i hate that baby i hate that baby
i hate this baby this baby is horrible
oh no baby
baby baby blunk
ah baby no oh no oh no
baby oh no oh no
put the bit oh baby on the lamp
baby on the lamp baby on the
spooky baby horrifying baby okay
put baby in high chair all right cool
thanks baby for being baby
i'm gonna go get you food where's my
kitchen
there it is all right baby i have no
food just this this is all i care about
the baby's well-being
you baby one's bottle
hate it hate everything hey oh no you're
smiling that's somehow worse
it's worse the smile is worse it's a
bouncing baby and a stinky baby
all right cool i'm gonna put you on the
changing table is this a changing table
where's it there it is
boink all right take all right do how do
i
there we go the worst
thing ever the worst thing
all right baby i'm not gonna ask too
many questions about
you and how horrible you are i'm just
gonna put you to bed
is this the baby's room this is the
baby's room
all right shall i sing you a lullaby
go to sleep go to
sleep please don't kill
me in the night
go to sleep please go to sleep
and for the love of god blink
and good night
all right good great
i'm very sorry what did i just see
in the painting let's just watch them
tivo let's watch some good tiva
hey listen all right
sleepy sleepy
oh
hey baby
baby you in the closet baby baby
baby oh no no
no oh no oh poor baby
oh no okay good
[Music]
it's a baby baby
oh the baby oh the baby
the baby will go good
bye
all right
all right all right
good stuff good stuff oh so sleepy oh
adam's family really gets me out oh
night too
oh good the child laughing look look
isn't it funny the sitter i told you not
to do that
oh good
oh great get the bottle from the fridge
okay
wait a second
hi hello again it's me
your favorite babysitter here to teach
you
how to be a baby properly number one
blink number two don't manipulate
the house with your powers from the
beyond
okay good glad hey let's go to the
changing table baby
can i put you in the trash can okay i'm
gonna
okay your head oh my goodness oh my
my word uh okay all right cool good
great good great good
good and dun dun dunk in the toilet
baby need to go to the bathroom
apparently baby need to go in the sink
baby need to look at take a long hard
look at yourself in the mirror i think
baby all right cool baby all right cool
doink i'm turning around uh
my your wait a minute
come back here come back here diaper
oh diapy talismans and their uses
in child care uh-huh okay cool
good great uh baby uh baby
um oh you're still there okay good i'm
gonna change it
all right you're very happy now let's
get you to bed thong thunk
i'm sorry i thunked you i'm very sorry i
thunked you
i did not mean to thunk you baby
all right great good job baby
great good baby good good baby
good excellent baby okay baby lullaby
um go to sleep you're a demon
your parents conceived you on
some kind of occult symbol and now
you're demon
and i don't know what to do about it
good night
all right time to go to bed
time to get some rest maybe call my
boyfriend
all right no boy man i love lucy
i sure do i love lucy night three good
night sweet dreams
i will show you my dreams
all right yeah show me your dreams
all right just chill out
there ain't even a baby here pick a baby
no baby all right cool i'll just chill
out
this
[Music]
all right then i will go take care of
the baby
[Music]
baby oh no baby oh no
all right good night no lullaby
sick of your [ __ ] all right cool good
night
perhaps a cheese toast
all right i'm getting this signal
that i need to feed the baby
man these parents
opted for the deluxe model
[Music]
all right we're all good here we're all
good
baby happy oh who's a stinky baby
ah who pooped a demon out nappy
i knew it oh that's normal
all right cool anyway see you around kid
let me know now i would like to go
please now is the time oh yeah the
talisman that's right i saw that hey you
wait right there baby
you wait right there hey baby
all right i need to exercise this baby
baby
i hate to say you're looking a little
flabby you know
can't even run a mile take this
oh did i not pick up the top all right
hang on a second baby i dropped it
apparently i think maybe
i don't know oh i did sure did all right
all right baby get ready because it's
about to get exorcismed
you're about to you do burpees take this
okay
[Music]
all right okay baby yeah yeah yeah
oh no i'm a baby
you done having a temper tantrum he done
having a bit of an ad
oh ah
oh oh okay
yeah i need a raise if i'm gonna sit
this baby
that was great i really loved that that
was fantastic
that was a great experience all good but
man that baby
high maintenance
hey
[Music]
you